l'ordre du jour appelle les questions au
gouvernement je vous rappelle les règles
dérogatoires d'organisation de nos
séances de questions en raison de la
crise sanitaire ne sont présents que
nombre limité des ministres et un seul
député par groupe les questions ayant le
même thème sont regroupés chaque
question faisant l'objet d'une réponse
spécifique
le nombre des questions et réduits en
revanche ces temps de parole sur le
temps usuelle des minutes par question
et autant par raiponce réplique ou
contre réplique éventuelles comprises
afin de limiter au maximum les effectifs
des personnels présents
je vous rappelle aussi que la liste des
orateurs dont vous avez connaissance
n'est pas affichés sur les écrans durant
la séance enfin les règles sanitaires
habituel continuent à s'appliquer
nettoyage des micros conscience les
orateurs sont invités à ne pas poser les
mains sur les micro utiliser des micros
différents respect des distances entre
les participants entrée et sortie
échelonnée
nous commençons notre séance par des
questions portant sur la crise du coït
19 en général et notamment le thème de
la santé
la parole est à monsieur arnaud viala
pour le groupe l'est républicain
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
j'associe à la question mes collègues
michel herbillon et olivier dassault
ainsi que l'ensemble des députés les
républicaine alors que l'académie de
médecine vient de préconiser le port
généralisé de masque pendant la période
de confinement et lors de sa levée
votre gouvernement se voit contraint
d'opérer une spectaculaire volte face
sur sa doctrine précisément concernant
les masques jusqu'à la semaine dernière
vous juger le port du masque
je cite inutile voire contre-productif
pour les personnes non infectées votre
porte parole soutenait même le 25 mars
dernier je la cite qu'il n'ya pas besoin
d'un masque quand on respecte la
distance de protection vis-à-vis des
autres désormais vous encourager le
grand public à porter des masques
alternatifs les masques chirurgicaux est
en réserve et c'est bien normal au
personnel soignant
ce revirement nous interroge
pourquoi ne pas avoir reconnu dès le
départ que nous manque que nous
manquions de masques et qu'il serait
distribué avec parcimonie
plutôt que de dire qu'il ne servait à
rien il convient désormais d'aller au
bout de votre logique en nous expliquant
à l'instar de certains maires qui
prennent les devants comment vous
comptez approvisionner la population à
masquer maintenant qu'ils vont devenir
indispensable pour circuler enfin une
fois l'ensemble des aidants et des
soignants servi
comment comptez vous aider les
innombrables professionnels de l'élevage
de l'agroalimentaire de la distribution
du btp des services du transport et
cetera qui travaille pour subvenir à nos
besoins et que pour certains vous
encourager à reprendre ou à poursuivre
leur activité à s'équiper correctement
comme vous le préconisez avec ses
masques et les autres équipements de
protection je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole à
monsieur olivier ferrand ministre des
solidarités et de la santé merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
arnaud viala je ne voudrais pas qu'il y
ait de confusion à la suite de votre
question et je vais essayer de vous
répondre le plus clairement possible
d'abord il n'y a aucune décision de
recommandations de port du masque ni
obligatoire ni recommandé en tout cas à
ce stade pour la population générale
nous en restons à l'heure à laquelle je
vous parle à la stratégie qui est de
permettre de protéger les soignants vous
l'avez dit vous-même par des masques
ffp2 ou des masques chirurgicaux les
soignants mais également les patients
les plus fragiles les personnes les plus
fragiles ou les personnes qui présentent
des risques particuliers
le premier ministre s'est engagé
résolument pour promouvoir une filière
industrielle en france à la fois dans le
textile et dans le papier de manière à
pouvoir
en complément des importations de
masques et de la production intensive
dans l'ensemble des filières de
production française des masques
alternatifs moins protecteur mais
protecteur quand même destinée à ce
qu'on appelle les 2e ligne dans le
combat contre le virus en priorité les
personnes qui sont en contact avec du
public mais qui n'exerce pas de fonction
de soins c'est à dire par exemple les
personnes dans les transports ou des
opérateurs qui sont en contact avec les
gens
quotidien dans leur mission enfin il y à
une question qui est soulevée mais qui
est une question qui est portée vous
l'avez dit par l'académie de médecine en
france mais qui est encore contestée par
de nombreux organismes scientifiques
internationaux qui est la question de
savoir si à terme il faudra proposer un
site et voir contraindre le port d'un
masque en population générale cette
question là elle est ouverte je le dis
avec humilité face à une menace
épidémique inédite et à mesure que les
recommandations scientifiques évolué
nous sommes amenés nous-mêmes à nous
interroger parfois nous réinterroger à
l'heure actuelle je ne peux que
confirmer ce qu'a dit la porte-parole du
gouvernement à savoir que les gestes
barrière la distanciation sociale le
lavage des mains le fait de tousser dans
son coude sont les mesures reconnues par
l' oms comme les plus efficaces
mais s'il s'avère que le port d'un
masque en population générale pouvait
permettre de renforcer l'efficacité du
dispositif si les recommandations des
scientifiques allaient dans ce sens
alors nous serions amenés à communiquer
en ce sens mais à ce stade je le redis
la doctrine n'a pas évolué merci
monsieur le ministre
la parole est un monsieur monsieur
classe bauer qui porte une question de
l'âme justine bénin
merci merci monsieur le président cette
question de justine bénin un député de
la guadeloupe à laquelle est associée
max mathiasin s'adresse à madame la
ministre d outre-mer le monde entier est
confronté à une crise sans précédent et
plus que jamais cette pandémie accentue
les inégalités sociales territoriales et
économique
ce constat est particulièrement vrai
pour nos outre-mer et singulièrement
pour la guadeloupe où le seuil
épidémique a été franchi il ya
maintenant plus de deux semaines vous
connaissez bien les difficultés de la
ministe de la guadeloupe
la fragilité de son système de santé les
problèmes liés aux soins à l'insularité
à l'emploi wac ou encore à la couverture
numérique
nos personnels soignants et nos
populations sont inquiètes et
s'interrogent légitimement sur leur
capacité à affronter l'épidémie masques
gants respirateur la guadeloupe comme
tous les territoires ultramarins ont
plus que jamais besoin de moyens massifs
pour répondre à cette crise les outre
mer ont besoin d'être rassurés madame la
ministre
aussi
pouvez-vous garantir l'envoi de matériel
de ressources humaines supplémentaires
pouvez vous aussi préciser les missions
du porte-hélicoptères dixmude mobilisés
aux antilles par ailleurs la crise
sanitaire s'ajoute une crise sociale
économique sur un territoire où le
chômage est déjà très fort bien plus
qu'ailleurs
si nous saluons tous les et ceux ci nous
saluons tous les effets le gouvernement
afin de soutenir les entreprises en
difficulté il est nécessaire d'étendre
cette action aux outre-mer les remontées
du terrain met en avant l'exclusion de
nombreuses tpe de ce dispositif du fait
de la complexité des caractères
notamment en matière de charges fiscales
ou sociales
aussi madame la ministre pouvait vous
garantir que le gouvernement s'engagera
pleinement au soutien de l'économie et
des emplois de l'outre-mer merci merci
chers collègues la parole et à madame
les jardins ministre d outre mer
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés sur le député
notre pays vous l'avez dit est frappé
par une crise aujourd'hui mondiale et
les territoires d'outre-mer
malheureusement ne sont pas épargnés
alors je comprends votre préoccupation
je prends je comprends la préoccupation
des députés de guadeloupe
max mathiasin et justine bénin et et
nous les partageons et c'est pour ça que
nous nous avons nous nous sommes
intervenus très vite il faut savoir
effectivement que notre priorité c'était
que le virus ne circule pas dans les
territoires d'outre-mer
et quand les décisions nationales ont
été prises nous les avons appliqué
immédiatement dans les territoires
d'outre-mer alors que l'épidémie n'était
absolument pas au même stade que dans
l'hexagone en parlait à ce moment là que
de quelques cas et puis nous avons des
mesures spécifiques dans les territoires
d'outre-mer nous avons fait en sorte de
limiter drastiquement lé vol en
direction des territoires d'outre-mer
quand des passagers arrivent dans les
territoires d'outre-mer ils ont une
14ème strictes à domicile ou dans des
structures collectives
nous avons mis en place également le
couvre-feu notamment en guadeloupe
concernant les moyens sanitaires ils ont
été renforcées et ça continue pour la
guadeloupe plus précisément 15
respirateur viennent d'arriver en
guadeloupe comme 23 professionnels de
santé de la réserve sanitaire
effectivement pour venir augmenter le
nombre de lits de réanimation une
information au jour
nous avons quinze patients hospitalisés
en rien des deux groupes et nous avons
39 lits aujourd'hui équipe et nous
allons continuer à monter en puissance
au fur et à mesure des semaines qui
passent c'est normal nous serons au
niveau de la réponse nécessaire le
dixmude vous en avez parlé ce
porte-hélicoptères il arrive bien tueur
en guadeloupe comme en martinique sur
l'ensemble des entités de lentilles
guyane il transporte du matériel par
exemple un million plus d'un million de
masques aujourd'hui pour pour ces ces
territoires
il sera là dans quelques jours il faut
12 jours pour traverser l'atlantique
et puis on a aussi bien sur une capacité
à bord de ses porte hélicoptères des
hélicoptères d'évacuation d'évacuation
sanitaire sur les mesures économiques
elles sont mises en place j'ai demandé
qu'ils aient des cellules d'urgence
piloté par les préfets dans chaque
territoire d'outre-mer sur les questions
économiques il y aura du cas par cas
nous l'avons déjà fait nous commence
nous qu'on veut continuerons à le faire
je suis en contact avec tous les élus en
permanence comme le premier ministre
comme le président de la république je
veux rappeler ici que les outre mer sont
une préoccupation de tous le
gouvernement de lanceurs tennessee la
parole est à monsieur jean louis bricout
pour le groupe socialiste et apparentés
merci monsieur le président j'associe
mes collègues du groupe donc à cette
question monsieur le premier ministre
depuis le début de cette crise sanitaire
notre pays confronté à une pénurie de
masse qui menacent notre capacité à
endiguer l'épidémie
notre pays est en guerre ce sont les
mots du président de la république
mais pour éviter que cette guerre contre
le virus se transforme en guerre de tous
contre tous permettez moi de vous poser
trois grandes questions pour mieux
connaître votre doctrine première
question depuis le 3 avril
les autorités sanitaires ont changé la
doctrine de et recommande le port
généralisé du masque alors que la
perspective d'un déconfinement a été
évoquée et compte tenu que bon nombre de
nos concitoyens un travail au quotidien
pour exercer des métiers dont dépend la
nation comment comptez vous équiper des
français en masques et surtout dès
aujourd'hui pour ceux qui doivent
travailler
envisagez-vous des distribution de
masques gratuite mais rationner dans des
pharmacies
pour permettre l'accès à tous mais
évitez aussi l'inflation ou la ruée vers
les masques la nécessité d'un discours
clair sur le sujet nous paraît
nécessaire
deuxième question selon les consignes de
certaines ars les aides à domicile
gnahoré n'aurait le droit qu'à neuf
masques par semaine or une aide à
domicile voie entre cinq et sept
patients par jour
comment comptez vous protéger le
personnel et nos aînés la troisième
question la région bourgogne franche
comté a effectué des commandes de
masques de commandes ont été
réquisitionnés par l'état sans
concertation alors même que la seconde
commande était concertée avec la région
grand est
or pour belfort et mulhouse le foyer de
l'épidémie n'est distant que de 40 km
pourquoi l'état de l'impression
d'abandonner les collectivités locales
en première ligne elle est un conte il
désormais organiser une répartition
transparente et solidaire des masques
entre les régions je remercie monsieur
merci la parole est à monsieur le
ministre des solidarités de la santé sur
l'évier vers ans merci monsieur le
président monsieur le député jean-louis
brico bricout d'abord les autorités
sanitaires n'ont pas changé la doctrine
il y à des discussions de scientifiques
organisées notamment une hausse à
l'académie de médecine qui propose une
évolution
d'autres n'ont pas encore statué sur la
question et nous avons saisi à la fois
le conseil scientifique et l'ensemble
des autorités de santé publique
le haut conseil de santé publique en
premier lieu pour les concerter sur
l'évolution éventuelle à apporter sur
cette question du port du masque comme
je lé répondu tout à l'heure à monsieur
viala vous dire que cette semaine nous
avons déstocker 45 millions de masques
45 millions de masques sur l'ensemble du
territoire national vous parlez de
solidarité à l'égard des régions vous
dire que vous cité l'exemple de la
région grand test que j'ai eu et premier
ministre a eu l'occasion de rappeler que
dans la région grand est
la consommation de masse et c'est normal
compte tenu de l'épidémie très forte
qu'ici est si répandue notamment dans le
bios pitallier la consommation de
masques a explosé de leurs 2 x 10 x 15 x
20 jusqu'à 70 ans certaines unités et
les hôpitaux de la région grand est ont
été
approvisionné en masque en matériel de
protection qu'ils savaient de l'effort
de la nation pour la région grand est
je crois et et haulotte à la hauteur de
l'ambition avec beaucoup d'évacuation
sanitaire est moche je tire mon chapeau
à l'ensemble des acteurs au sein des
agences mais au surtout au sein des
hôpitaux qui ont réussi à se mobiliser
et faire en sorte que le pic épidémique
que il nous semble avoir passé dans
cette région en tout cas nous y sommes a
pu être passé dans l'est dans des
conditions extrêmement dures du point de
vue du prix de l'organisation des soins
mais de manière remarquable du point de
vue humain je ne vous parle pas des tgv
des avions des hélicoptères je crois que
la solidarité de l'état vis-à-vis des
territoires qui étaient en tension et la
solitaire la solidarité des régions
vis-à-vis des régions en tension a été
pleine et entière et enfin vous dire que
sur les secteurs des aides à domicile
comme des ehpad
non seulement nous discutions du
matériel de protection à mesure que nos
moyens nous le permettre mais en plus
j'ai annoncé hier une politique de
dépistage massif qui va permettre de
renforcer la protection des personnes
les plus fragiles et notamment les aînés
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à madame béatrice descamps pour le
groupe udi agir merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre des solidarités de
la santé monsieur le ministre le groupe
udi agirait indépendant m'accompagne
pour saluer tout d'abord la très forte
mobilisation et l'engagement sans faille
des personnels des et fade leur travail
remarquable ces femmes et ces hommes
font la démonstration d'une formidable
solidarité et de cela nous devrons nous
en souvenir
bien que nous manquions encore de
chiffres il est incontestable que la
situation des états touchés par le cos
vide 19 est très préoccupante
la mortalité y est anormalement élevé on
compte plusieurs décès par jour dans
certains établissements
le manque de données notamment au niveau
des pourcentages des papes touchés ne
donne pas le sentiment de la
transparence totale dont les soignants
et les familles des pensionnaires au
besoin certains refus d'hospitalisation
d'aînés signifie t'il que la priorité
n'est pas consacré aux plus fragiles
le sentiment d'abandon les problèmes
psychologiques et les nombre important
de nombre de d2d
et l épidémie sont choquants tant pour
le personnel que pour les résidents et
leurs familles à permettre aux résidents
d'aller vivre momentanément chez leurs
enfants restent aussi une question
récurrente sans réponse
nos aînés sont ils suffisamment pris en
compte dans certaines régions les ars ne
donne toujours pas de masque aux ehpad
qui n'ont à ce jour pas de cas de co
vide les ehpad les résidences les
établissements accueillant des personnes
handicapées n'ont pas été suffisamment
tôt protéger nous le savons faute de
moyens de protection aussi pouvez vous
monsieur le ministre nous rassurer cette
fois pour demain monsieur le premier
ministre vous avez annoncé des tests
systématiques pour les résidents et
salariés de ces établissements nous en
entendons beaucoup parler depuis ce
matin pouvez vous nous donner des
précisions comme pour le regroupement
dont on parle des malades du cobp id
je vous en remercie merci monsieur
olivier viron ministre des solidarités
et de la santé madame la députée des
camps le 11 mars nous avons annoncé la
suspension des visites extérieures au
sein des ehpad le déclenchement du plan
bleu le 28 mars nous avons appelé avec
le premier ministre
un renforcement des mesures de
protection des mesures difficile
humainement jusqu'à jusqu'au confinement
en chambre pour des personnes âgées déjà
fragile mais parce qu'il le fallait pour
pouvoir les protéger je suis même allé
jusqu'à appeler les ehpad qu'il le
pouvait a invité le personnel à rester
sur place
ce qu est ce qui montre à nouveau le
sens du sacrifice et l'altruisme total
des acteurs du monde de la santé du
monde du social du médico social envers
les personnes les plus fragiles sur les
équipements nous n'avons jamais nié les
difficultés
s'agissant des aides à domicile par
exemple des difficultés logistiques
importantes la distribution au sein des
groupements hospitalier de territoire a
permis d'améliorer considérablement la
situation pour les ehpad et les aides à
domicile et le soutien précieux des
départements qui nous a tout de suite
nous ont toutes eu tendu la main nous a
permis je crois d'améliorer les circuits
de distribution de manière conséquente
il peut encore y avoir des difficultés
mais je crois que vraiment un effort
remarquable a été fait par tous sur les
tests le dépistage sera systématique
progressivement déployée sur le
territoire
évidemment à nouveau en lien avec les
collectivités territoriales au premier
lieu les départements qui font appel à
des personnes volontaires de la réserve
sanitaire pour aller faire des
prélèvements à des véhicules parfois
prêté par le département parfois par les
agences régionales de santé
nous sommes en train de faire la liste
de tous les laboratoires disponible et
vous savez que j'ai autorisé tous les
laboratoires y compris les laboratoires
départementaux à participer à l'effort
national de tests de manière à ce que
dès qu'il ya un cas authentifié dans un
ehpad on puisse dépister l'ensemble des
personnes tout cela vous l'imaginez
prend du temps c'est une logistique
extrêmement complexe la mobilisation de
tous est nécessaire
enfin sur la transparence madame la
députée elle est totale allez total les
chiffres que nous annonçons tous les
soirs sont les chiffres qui lui sont
remontés quotidiennement par l'ensemble
des ehpad établissements médico sociaux
du territoire
nous sommes le seul pays à faire la
transparence totale sur le nombre de
départs concernés le nombre de malades
par ehpad et même jusqu'à la mortalité
nous faisons extrêmement attention aux
personnes les plus fragiles
encore une fois c'est la priorité des
priorités pour nous merci monsieur le
ministre la parole de monsieur paul
molac pour le groupe ' liberté et
territoires sur le président monsieur le
ministre les personnes fragiles sont les
premières touchées par le coup vite 19
c'est particulièrement vrai s'agissant
des personnes en situation de handicap
et les personnes âgées résidant dans un
établissement médico sociaux la
situation dans ces structures est
particulièrement préoccupant entre d'une
part le confinement est difficile à
mettre en place et expliquer aux
résidents d'autre part la propagation
est facilitée par la promiscuité
il a fallu attendre jeudi dernier pour
connaître la réelle ampleur de
l'épidémie au sein des ehpad et des
établissements médico sociaux avec un
bilan particulièrement lourd puisque
plus de 2000 personnes y sont décédées
dans ce contexte certaines associations
s'inquiètent que les personnes en
situation d'handicap puissent se voir
refuser des soins hospitaliers
lorsqu'elles sont contaminées par le
virus de telles pratiques si elle était
avérée ce serait absolument intolérable
nous avons conscience de l'incroyable
effort qui est menée partout par les
personnels de santé pour assurer la
prise en charge de tous néanmoins dans
les régions les plus touchées
il faut avoir la certitude que le niveau
d'autonomie et de dépendance des
personnes n'est pas devenu un critère
d'admission ou non à l'hôpital
il est indispensable de réaffirmer que
la protection de ces publics fragiles
est une priorité
aussi monsieur le ministre quels sont
les engagements clairs que vous pouvez
prendre devant nous afin de garantir que
le handicap physique ou psychique ne
soit pas et ne devienne pas un critère
de refus d'hospitalisation
enfin pour assurer effectivement c'est
cette préoccupation
vous venez de répondre tout à l'heure au
dépistage qui sera systématique
est-ce que vous pouvez nous donner un
terme c'est à dire est ce qu'on y
arrivera dans peu de temps où est ce que
on va encore mettre beaucoup de passes
que il faut avoir du réactif il faut
avoir un certain nombre de je suppose
que ça ne se fait pas comme ça
merci monsieur les budgets la parole à
monsieur olivier véran ministre des
solidarités et de la fonte et monsieur
le député paul molac vous avez raison ça
ne se fait pas comme ça ça nécessite une
logistique très complexe j'en parlais
tout à l'heure l'appui des départements
sera précieux l'organisation au sein des
agences régionales de santé pour
fonctionner territoire par territoire
l'appui des ehpad d'ailleurs à commencer
par les ehpad qui doivent pouvoir et je
le sais quel le est qu'elles le font se
mobiliser pour nous dire lorsqu'il ya
des difficultés lorsqu'elles ont besoin
d aide
c'est l'ensemble des services de l'état
des collectivités les associations les
communes aussi qu'ils doivent participer
à cet effort national et je peux vous
dire pour avoir appelé des élus de tous
bords et de toutes collectivités que
systématiquement la main a été tendue et
je crois que à nouveau l'union nationale
est importante et même elle est belle à
voir dans cette période parce que
l'objectif de protéger des personnes la
plus folle les plus fragiles est
évidemment partagée par tout vous dire
sur la question du refus leçon
hospitalier pour des personnes pour
raison de handicap ou de perte
d'autonomie nous avons tenu une
conférence de presse avec sophie cluzel
samedi au cours de laquelle nous avons
eu l émoi l'occasion d'affirmer avec la
plus grande détermination qu'il était
inconcevable
impensable que quelques obstacles à
l'accès aux soins puisse être prononcée
en raison d'une situation de handicap
physique psychique et mentale hors de
question je crois que le trouble
est venue par la publication malheureuse
sur le site internet d'une agence
régionale de santé d'un document interne
lui-même un peu malheureux qui n'avaient
pas été modifiées par une société
savante de réanimation le document été
immédiatement corrigée
les personnes s'en sont expliqués et
cela ne reflète absolument pas la
réalité comment imaginer que dans un
pays comme la france lors même que nous
allions les héros qui sauve des vies au
quotidien
il y aurait des personnes capables de
faire le tri en fonction du handicap et
permettez moi de saluer aussi l'ensemble
du monde de la santé mentale de la
psychiatrie je les ai réunis ce matin au
téléphone pour les saluer ils font un
travail remarquable dans des conditions
extrêmement difficiles
vous imaginez avec le confinement dans
des hôpitaux psychiatriques peut être
encore plus dur
je salue l'engagement de l'ensemble des
soignants de la filière de santé mentale
je crois qu'on ne le fait pas
suffisamment chapeau pour ce qu'ils font
et avec un résultat exceptionnel en
matière de prévention et de préservation
de ces établissements sans merci
monsieur le ministre
la parole est un monsieur eric coquerel
pour le groupe france monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre
question est posée aux milices de la
solidarité de la santé vous affirmiez le
4 avril que les livraisons de masques ou
personnels soignants sont désormais
hebdomadaire
pourtant les protections de toutes
sortes continue en réalité à manquer
cruellement dans certains hôpitaux
notamment dans les régions grand test et
ile de france
les récits des personnels soignants sont
glaçant sur blues absente ou se
déchirant à cause de leur mauvaise
qualité masque rationner arrivant même
parfois moisi nous les entendons nous
les avons interrogés c'est la débrouille
nous distille le système d le chu de
lille ah mais mis en place un atelier de
couture pour fabriquer des blues tandis
que les hospices civils de lyon propose
un tuto pour fabriquer des tabliers avec
des sacs poubelles
du côté du grand test hier sur france 3
la chef des urgences de l'hôpital de
sarreguemines affirmé hier encore ne
toujours pas recevoir de masquer l'état
mais uniquement de solidarité venant du
domaine privé plutôt que de fournir des
masses dans cette même région en
souffrance en pleine crise la rs a
envisagé de fermer près de 200 lits et
600 postes à nancy résultat en pleine
phase de l'aggravation de la crise leurs
preuves au terme de ce matin de nombreux
personnels soignants se sentent
abandonnés par l'état et beaucoup
restent démunis
en protection au péril de leur vie et
des nôtres le pire c'est que vous
menacer certains même de sanctions comme
à hautmont dans le nord étant donné la
gravité de la situation je vous demande
donc monsieur le ministre nous donner
aujourd'hui est donnée aux soignants qui
nous entendent
des éléments précis et clair sans
annonce globale
qu'en est il exactement des cinq cent
mille masques par jour que vous avez
promis le 4 avril au secteur
médico-social convient ont été
distribuées depuis combien le seront
d'ici la fin de la semaine
quelle commande exact ont été faites y
compris pour les autres protections
nécessaires comme les blues qu'elle
marchait avez-vous conclu de manière
certaine auprès de quelle entreprise et
pour quels délais depuis en plus qu'on
sait que les masques de chine
n'arriveront pas avant fin juin comme
l'a dit monsieur le drian ce matin merci
monsieur le député la parole est à
monsieur olivier véran ministre des
solidarités et de la santé monsieur le
député coquerel je vais essayer de vous
répondre de façon la plus factuelle
possible je vous invite à essayer d'être
factuel aussi dans les questions que
vous posez
parce qu'il ya pardon beaucoup d'erreurs
d'abord je ne menace personne de
sanction ou alors vous venez me
m'expliquer qui comment et par quoi
quand vous dites vous menacez c'est
presque une accusation pardonnez-moi
calomnieuse je ne menace personne je
vois une faute oui de la tête
nous sommes donc d'accord sur ce premier
sur cette première assertion qui étaient
fausses la deuxième vous dites que les
masques n'arrive pas de chine
la totalité des masques que nous avons
commandé j'ai annoncé le chiffre d'un
milliard scission millions de masques
qui sont en production fiable dont 70%
en provenance de la chine
ces masques qu'ils arrivent
régulièrement 20 millions de masques la
semaine dernière 25 millions de masques
cette semaine en plus de la production
française monsieur coquerel vous ne
demandez des chiffres je vous les donne
vous dire également que les 500 mille
masques que les secteurs médico-social a
demandé chaque jour ce sont les 500
mille masques que nous délivrons que lui
des stocks ont par semaine pour chaque
journée travaillée c'est à dire qu'ils
ont l'équivalent de 500 mille masques la
logistique monsieur coquerel ne vous
aura pas échappé peut être complexe et
il peut y avoir des endroits et croyez
bien que je le regrette je le regrette
parce que ce n'est pas normal mais il y
a effectivement des endroits où la
logistique peut pêcher les l'équivalent
de 500 mille masques chirurgicaux par
jour sont des stockés depuis la demande
du secteur médico social en leur
direction
poser la question des blues
des sur blues nous avons distribué 400
milles blues supplémentaires nous avons
commandé 5 millions de blues ainsi que
des masques ainsi que ainsi que des
gants ainsi que des charlottes
l'explosion de la consommation
hospitalière monsieur coquerel dans les
endroits les plus lents en tension du
point de vue épidémique peut poser des
tensions sur l'accès à du matériel de
protection à nouveau croyez bien que je
le regrette
nous avons multiplié par trois les lits
de réanimation dans les hôpitaux de la
région du grand est monsieur coquerel ça
veut dire que quand vous multiplié par
trois et que vous avez du personnel de
la réserve sanitaire de la ville de
l'hôpital qui viennent en soutien
effectivement ça augmente très fortement
les consommations à nous de protéger ce
qui nous protège vous avez raison mais
nous mettons tous les moyens en place
pour pouvoir le faire dans les
meilleures conditions possibles jeu
concret encore une fois c'est pas l'état
c'est pas l'état que vous visez en ce
sens là c'est l'ensemble des acteurs des
agences notent de santé de l'assurance
maladie de la sécurité sociale des
hôpitaux des aides à domicile qui se
mobilisent y compris sur les territoires
pour trouver des solutions quand c'est
particulièrement merci jésus mais c'est
ce que je souhaite saluer à travers
cette réponse merci monsieur le ministre
la parole à monsieur stéphane peu pour
le groupe de la gauche démocrate et
républicaine
merci monsieur le ministre de la santé
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire
les personnels hospitaliers
accomplissent un travail exceptionnel
pour lutter contre l'épidémie qui frappe
notre pays malgré des pénuries de
masques de blues de respirateurs leur
sens du dévouement et exemplaires chacun
mesure combien notre système public de
santé est un bien commun qu'il nous faut
préserver renforcé pour répondre aux
défis de l'avenir
dans ce contexte nous sommes
profondément choqués par les propos
tenus ce week-end par le directeur de la
rs du grand est confirmant en pleine
crise sanitaire
la suppression de 581 18 emplois et 274
lits à l'hôpital de nancy
ses propos indécents font également écho
à une note de la caisse des dépôts du 26
mars dernier commandé par vous même et
par le président de la république loin
d'envisager un plan massif
d'investissement dans l'hôpital public
ce document ne fait que reprendre les
recettes éculées qui ont affaibli le
service public de santé en prévoyant une
privatisation rampante et en poursuivant
la marchandisation des soins
depuis janvier 2018 et le début de notre
tour de france des hôpitaux nous
parlementaires communistes vous alertons
sur la situation de crise que connaît
l'hôpital tout en mettant sur la table
des propositions
cette crise révèle qu encore plus
l'exigence d'abandonner les orientations
de ces trente dernières années
conduisant aux suppressions d'emplois et
aux suppressions de lits monsieur le
ministre des propos de certains
responsables d'administrations ou les
recommandations des milieux financiers
nous inquiète et inquiète le pays sur
l'avenir de l'hôpital public alors
pouvez vous nous préciser
et pourquoi pas nous rassurer sur l'état
d'esprit qui est le vôtre et celui du
gouvernement sur l'avenir de l'hôpital
public au sortir de cette crise
sanitaire
merci chers collègues la parole à
monsieur olivier ferrand ministre des
solidarités et de la santé monsieur le
député stéphane peu je crois que l'état
d'esprit
s'agissant de l'avenir de l'hôpital et
notamment s'agissant de l'hôpital de
nancy nous sommes pas loin de partager
l'émotion je la comprends parfaitement
suite à l'intervention d'un serviteur de
l'état qui a cru bien faire j'imagine en
rappelant un plan de réorganisation
j'ai immédiatement dit publiquement que
tous les plans de réorganisation de
restructurer de restructuration de
réduction de lee était suspendu leurs
ailes et à la mobilisation de tous elle
est à la mobilisation avec les soignants
qui sauvent des vies et je crois que
dans le jour d'après cette crise
sanitaire
nous aurons à repenser jeu reprend les
mots du président de la république qu'il
a prononcé à mulhouse le 23 mars dernier
nous aurons à repenser notre modèle
sanitaire notre modèle hospitalier pour
tenir compte de ce que cette crise
sanitaire nous enseigne avec ce cas-là
d'incroyablement réussi pour l'hôpital
comme cette augmentation du nombre de
lits de réanimation
comme cette mobilisation sans faille
comme cette capacité de réaction qui
fait que partout le pic est très élevé
nous faisons face et nous soignons font
face avec bravoure et courage et tenir
aussi compte des tensions et des
implications sur l'organisation du parc
hospitalier sur les plans d'organisation
de financement tous et toutes ces
questions fondamentales ainsi que sur
les carrières le premier ministre a
écrit lui-même au président de la
commission médicale d'établissement et
au directeur général de l'hôpital de
nancy pour les rassurer également sur la
situation nancéenne
je ne peux pas être plus clair je crois
que ce que j'ai été et que ce que le
premier ministre a lui-même écrit merci
monsieur le ministre la parole est à
monsieur marc delattre
pour le groupe e la république en marche
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame frédéric vidal
ministre de la recherche et de
l'enseignement supérieur
j'y associe mon collègue françois de
rugy madame la ministre les chercheurs
dans cette guerre contre le coronavirus
sont en première ligne
les formes d'un bataillon d'excellence
que ce soit à l'institut pasteur où plus
de 300 chercheurs sont mobilisés à
l'inserm ou partout ailleurs dans les
centres de recherche des femmes et des
hommes travaillent d'arrache-pied pour
trouver des solutions efficaces contre
le virus
la recherche médicale française et
depuis des siècles à la pointe de la
recherche internationale nous le devons
à de grands noms de notre histoire
louis-pasteur marie curie bien
évidemment mais aussi plus près de nous
jules hoffmann ou françoise barré
sinoussi
cette excellence est aussi le fruit d'un
engagement permanent de l'état depuis
des décennies et en annonçant 5
milliards d'euros supplémentaires pour
la recherche dont 20 milliards dédiés à
la santé
le président de la république affirme la
volonté de la france au sein de l'europe
quant à demeurer à la pointe de la
recherche internationale s'il est trop
tôt pour déterminer avec précision
comment seront répartis ces crédits
supplémentaires il est à noter que des
financements en urgence ont d'ores et
déjà été attribués pour onze projets de
recherche liés aux copies de 19
ces projets portés par des chercheurs
français d'excellence sont une source
d'espoir pour nous tous
pouvez vous madame la ministre nous
donner davantage d'informations sur ces
projets ainsi que peut-être deux
premières grandes orientations pour les
crédits supplémentaires qui seront
alloués à la recherche et par ailleurs
les biotech qui ont souvent une
expérience d'agilité unique dans le
paysage de la recherche médicale
sont aujourd'hui confrontés à des
difficultés pour présenter leur projet
commun de 19 auprès des pouvoirs publics
et obtenir si ces projets sont jugés
pertinents
des financements en urgence ainsi madame
la ministre ne serait-il pas possible de
mettre en place un fonds de soutien de
ses projets thérapeutiques spécifiques
aux qu'ovide 19 portées par des biotech
lorsqu'ils peuvent être mis en essais
cliniques dans un délai court
voilà je vous remercie merci monsieur le
député la parole est à madame frédéric
vidal ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur de la recherche et de
l'innovation
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
vous avez eu raison de rappeler monsieur
le député l'excellence de la recherche
française et la façon dont elle s'est
engagée parce que nous avions un
dispositif nommé reacting qui nous
permettait de faire une veille
épidémique est de maintenir en alerte
depuis les anciennes crise épidémique
comme mika ou au chikungunya un certain
nombre d' équipes de recherche
spécialisé en infectiologie
c'est ce qui nous a permis dès le mois
de février de soutenir 20 projets de
recherche en urgence notamment des
débuts de tests cliniques
c'est ce qui nous a permis aussi de
soutenir au travers de 16 millions
d'euros supplémentaires 44 projets qui
ont été soumis à l' agence nationale de
la recherche et de façon générale c'est
un fonds de 50 millions d'euros
supplémentaires qui a été débloqué pour
que pas un seul projet capable de nous
informer sur l'histoire naturelle du
virus sur la façon dont il se propage
sur les liens entre les aspects
cliniques et la réponse immunitaire sur
la façon dont la réplication de ce virus
se fait de façon différente dans des
populations différentes
tous ces projets seront évidemment
financé au delà de ces projets dans le
domaine de la biologie
nous finançons aussi des projets dans le
cadre des sciences humaines et sociales
pour nous permettre là aussi de mieux
comprendre quelle est la réaction des
populations à ce que nous sommes en
train de vivre leur réaction confinement
comment lutter contre les fausses
nouvelles qui font parfois autant de mal
que l'infection virale elle
m comment maintenir la meilleure
compréhension possible de nos
concitoyens de cette chose absolument
exceptionnel qui est en train de leur
arrivée au delà c'est effectivement 4
milliards d'euros qui sont mis à
disposition de l'ensemble des personnes
qui seront capables d'apporter des
solutions technologiques ou
thérapeutique les biotech en font bien
sûr partie et c'est le rôle du comité
d'analysé recherche et expertises que de
nous proposer toute solution viable
extrêmement rapidement et lui porter ce
regard scientifique sur ce qui est
proposé par les biotech jour merci merci
madame la ministre la parole monsieur
arnaud viala pour le groupe l'est
républicain
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre sont associés à ma
question jean jacques gauthier et
fabrice brunet ainsi que l'ensemble des
députés du groupe l'est républicain
monsieur le premier ministre nous ne
pouvons nous ne pouvons pas revivre avec
les tests de dépistage le même manque
d'anticipation et la même situation de
pénurie que nous connaissons encore
aujourd'hui avec les masques et
équipements de protection l'om et ne
cesse de le répéter le dépistage massif
est le meilleur rempart pour endiguer
efficacement le coronavirus pourtant le
diagnostic fait cruellement défaut en
france est votre stratégie de dépistage
suscite des questions il existe
actuellement deux types de tests
d'une part la recherche du virus lui
même parent prélèvements dans le nez
avec la technique dite pcr sur
ordonnance est remboursé par la sécurité
sociale
hélas ce test est réservé aux seuls
soignants symptomatique
alors que 30 % des patientes peuvent
être asymptomatique pourquoi pourquoi au
sein de la population générale limitée
le test aux seuls patients graves et
hospitalisé la deuxième méthode c'est le
test par sérologie c'est à dire par la
recherche des anticorps anti coronavirus
par prise de sang
ces tests sérologiques sont utilisés en
chine et en allemagne et s'avère
extrêmement performant depuis le 1er
avril
ils sont disponibles en france dans
certains laboratoires pour un coût
d'environ 60 euros dès lors pourquoi la
sérologie n'était toujours pas
remboursé par la sécurité sociale quand
le sera t-elle sachant qu'il faut
impérativement éviter un dépistage à
deux vitesses monsieur le premier
ministre la généralisation du dépistage
est absolument fondamental pour réussir
notre sortie du confinement le moment
venu pouvez vous s'il vous plaît nous
dire précisément comment vous entendez
mener cette bataille scientifique et
logistique de grande ampleur merci
monsieur le député la parole est à
monsieur olivier ferrand ministre des
solidarités et de la santé à nouveau
monsieur le député arnaud viala je crois
qu'il faut être extrêmement précis et
factuels deux types de tests ou plutôt
trois le test par pcr qui permet de
savoir si quelqu'un est symptomatique ou
s'il est porteur du virus au moment où
il présente des symptômes
il est effectivement réservé à des
personnes symptomatique qui présente des
critères de gravité des fragilités ou
qui sont amenés à être en contact avec
des personnes fragiles comme les
soignants par exemple nous amplifions il
y a eu 22 mille tests réalisés la
semaine dernière en moyenne chaque jour
vingt-deux mille tests et nous avons
annoncé que nous étions en train
d'augmenter ces tests jusqu'à cinquante
mille tests jour au cours du mois
d'avril et ski notamment va nous
permettre de dépister massivement dans
les ehpad deuxième type de test à
nouveau pour savoir si quelqu'un est
malade
ce sont les fameux tests rapides
antigénique dont on espérait qu'ils
arrivent et pour lesquels nous avions
passé des commandes mais qui n'existe
encore nulle part en phase
d'industrialisation suffisante et des
tests américains qui sont en train de
fabriquer ils arriveront sur notre
territoire national nous avons commandé
par an millions en millions
d'exemplaires et quand ils seront
disponibles nous les aurons et nous
pourrons l'ajouter au total de tests que
nous faisons par pcr et puis il ya le
sujet très important des sérologies
c'est ce qui me permet non pas savoir si
vous êtes malade au moment où on fait le
test mais si vous avez été immunisés
serre si vous avez des anticorps contre
le virus qui fait que si je puis me
permettre l'expression vous êtes
tranquilles sérologie elles ne sont pas
disponibles dans des pays différents du
nôtre
et nous ne sommes pas dépourvus
davantage que les autres en réalité la
recherche l'innovation et le
développement viennent d'aboutir sur des
tests sérologiques à l'étranger comme en
france et nous avons passé et nous
sommes en train de passer les commandes
nécessaires alors que l'innovation est
là elle vient juste d'arriver
nous sommes en phase de
pré-industrialisation ces tests
sérologiques et donc nous sommes amenés
à nous en équipe et ça tombe bien on a
des producteurs des producteurs français
très prometteur l'ensemble de ces tests
monsieur le député que l'ensemble des
soins dans notre pays et c'est la fierté
de notre nation et de notre modèle de
protection sociale sont évidemment qui
en charge par l'assurance maladie
merci monsieur le ministre la parole et
à monsieur paul pardon à logiciel de
buté excusez moi juste complément de
questions quand quand la sérologie quand
les technologies sont disponibles sur
ministre merci paul molac pour le groupe
liberté et territoires merci monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
voilà aujourd'hui trois semaines que le
confinement s'est imposé à nous comme la
seule solution pour ralentir l'épidémie
de covile 19
il était nécessaire nous l'avons soutenu
nos efforts collectifs vont commencer à
produire leurs effets ils ne doivent pas
se relâcher
alors que nous n'avons pas encore
stabilisé la pandémie vos propos sur le
déconfinement ont inquiété de nombreux
français parce que mal préparé mal
anticipé il se des confirmands pourrait
provoquer une nouvelle flambée de
contamination et son lot de décès la
situation actuelle en chine d'ailleurs
n'est pas pour nous rassurer
or quelle que soit la stratégie qui sera
décidé cela ne pourra se faire sans
véritables moyens pour surveiller l'état
immunitaire de la population et éviter
la contagion
on a des tests sérologiques fiable
monsieur le ministre viennent nous le
dire c'est une bonne nouvelle
alors moi aussi je réitère quand est ce
qu'on sera en mesure finalement de
tester la population est ce que ce sera
fin avril
fin mai parce qu'évidemment et on ne
pourra pas lutter contre le virus hand
et confinant si on n'a pas les moyens
pour le faire sur les masques quand
l'académie de médecine nous dit que ça
peut être une bonne chose est que dans
ce que j'ai lu on me dit plus ou moins
que jules
je ne l'avais pas dit avant parce qu'il
y en avait pas assez forcément ça
entretient un certain trouble de la part
de nos concitoyens forcément et donc la
question qu'on se pose une fois le
déconfinement fait fondre les masques
pour tout le monde c'est à dire qu'il
faut multiplier par trois ou quatre le
nombre de masques que l'on donne à
toutes les personnes
donc on voit bien là est ce que nous
aurons les moyens de le faire sachant
que d'autres prix viennent comme quoi il
y aurait des quantités de masques qui
seraient négociés sur les tarmacs des
aéroports chinois au plus offrant donc
c'est là où on a un peu de mal à
comprendre parce que j'ai l'impression
qu'on essaye d'avoir le coup d'après
mais que finalement on n'est déjà pas
clair sur ce que l'on a en ce moment
merci monsieur le député la parole
monsieur de premier ministre ce député
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
monsieur le député voilà que vous
évoquez la question de demain ou en
vérité d'ailleurs même plus tôt d'après
demain c'est à dire ce qui se passera
lorsque nous serons prêts à procéder à
ce déconfinement dont certains parlent
donc un seul enjeu par le peux je
réponds aux questions qu'on pose mais je
parle peu pourquoi parce que nous sommes
en train d'y travailler
ce n'est pas pour demain aujourd'hui
l'impératif c'est de faire en sorte que
le confinement fonctionne l'impératif
c'est de faire en sorte que le circus
virus le le virus circule suffisamment
lentement pour que le nombre de cas
sévères qui justifie l'admission dans
les services de réanimation ne sont pas
supérieures au nombre de la capacité
globale de notre de notre système
hospitalier
donc aujourd'hui c'est l'heure du
confinement et lors du confinement va
durer et c'est tout à fait difficile à
supporter pour beaucoup de français j'en
ai parfaitement conscience mais c'est
indispensable si nous ne voulons pas
nous retrouver dans une situation qui
serait pire encore que celle que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup
de questions qui sont liées aux
déconfinement demain ou après-demain
beaucoup
elles sont compliquées parce que pour
beaucoup d'entre elles elles tiennent à
des éléments dont nous ne disposons pas
encore à des réponses dont nous ne
disposons pas encore c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous nous préparons se
préparer ça ne veut pas dire que ces
prêts se préparer ça veut dire
travailler techniquement
scientifiquement logistiquement pour
être prêt le moment venu
c'est ce que nous sommes en train de
faire c'est un exercice difficile je les
dis nous en évoqueront les éléments
essentiels
lorsque les hypothèses sur lesquelles
nous travaillons seront vérifiés lorsque
les scénarii seront écrits mais pour
l'instant monsieur le député
toutes ces questions sont très largement
prématuré ce qui compte c'est de faire
en sorte que le confinement soit
respectée pour soulager nos services
hospitaliers qui en ont bien besoin vous
le savez nous savons tous de façon à
pouvoir préparer la suite merci monsieur
le premier ministre
la parole est à monsieur marc de lattes
pour une question de madame fiona lazard
pour le groupe la république en marche
merci monsieur le président la question
de ma collectionna lazare s'adresse à la
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
la santé des solidarités notre pays
affronte une crise sans précédent et
l'état plus que jamais de répondre
présent il doit répondre présent pour
lutter contre une crise sanitaire qui
touche tout le territoire
il doit répondre présent pour lutter
contre une crise économique qui touche
les entreprises les indépendants les
salariés à ces deux fronts qui mobilise
pleinement le parlement le gouvernement
et l'ensemble des pouvoirs publics
s'ajoute un troisième front qui est
celui des inégalités car ce que nous
enseigne aussi cette épreuve collective
c'est que nous ne sommes pas tous égaux
face à l'épidémie cette crise agit
depuis plusieurs semaines comme un
révélateur des inégalités sociales et
territoriales est plus que jamais cette
crise met au défi nos solidarités
collectives
aujourd'hui les personnes les plus
vulnérables sont particulièrement
victimes de l'épidémie de ses
conséquences c'est le cas des personnes
sans abri des personnes migrantes comme
en témoigne la situation d'urgence à
grande synthe de toutes les personnes
qui vivent de l'économie informelle et
sont privés de ressources mais c'est
aussi le cas de nombreuses familles
précaires qui n'ont pas les moyens de
faire face à la crise
quand on vit dehors quand on occupe
logement sion peuple et cantons
continuent d'aller travailler comme
livreur qui essayait de supermarchés
éboueurs souvent en utilisant les
transports communs il est plus difficile
de se protéger de la maladie
la fermeture des écoles et des cantines
rajoute elle au panier de courses de
famille déjà bien modeste alors même que
le suivi des classes à distance pénalise
les familles n'étant pas équipés ou en
capacité d'accompagner l'apprentissage
de leurs enfants
des mesures importantes ont été prises
et il faut les saluer l'ouverture de
places d'hébergement d'urgence la
création d'une réserve civique le
soutien à l'aide alimentaire
à l'heure où les solidarités familiales
et de proximité sont rendus plus
difficiles pour le confinement madame
lazare souhaite insister sur l'urgence
de renforcer notre action à destination
des plus démunis et pour reprendre les
mots des ministres la protection des
plus fragiles et la priorité des
priorités
ainsi elle souhaiterait vous interrogez
madame la ministre sur les actions
complémentaires qui peuvent être
engagées pour soutenir nos concitoyens
les plus vulnérables dans cette crise et
notamment sur l'opportunité d'une
allocation exceptionnelle de solidarité
afin de venir aux aides en aide aux
familles modestes merci merci monsieur
le député la parole la parole est à mme
dames christelle du boss secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre des
solidarités et de la santé merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
il n'y a pas une personne en france dans
le quotidien n'est pas impacté par la
crise épidémique que nous traversons le
gouvernement livre un combat sur tous
les fronts pour que notre pays affronte
cette crise qui n'a pas de précédent
donc travaillent aux côtés du ministre
olivier ferrand c'est que la solidarité
nationale soit présente pour aider les
plus fragiles et tous ceux qui ont
besoin des aides en cette période de
crise le président de la république l'a
réaffirmé la crise épidémique ne doit
pas mener le drap un drame social
le premier enjeu c'est le maintien de
l'aide alimentaire grâce au soutien des
volontaires qui se sont mobilisés sur la
plateforme de la réserve civique mais
aussi surtout grâce aux associations et
aux centres communaux d'action sociale
qui plus que jamais se dépassent pour
faire l'impossible avec julien de
normandie nous distribuons des chèques
services pour les sans abri qui
rencontreraient des difficultés d'accès
aux biens de première nécessité
le deuxième objectif c'est la continuité
du travail social pour accompagner les
fragile cela se fait notamment avec le
soutien des étudiants en travail social
volontaire que j'ai mobilisé avec l'unaf
au risque en créant cette réserve
sociale le troisième enjeu c'est le
maintien du versement des aides sociales
pendant toute la durée de la crise et
qui sont automatiquement prolongé
lorsque les locataires ne peuvent pas
faire leurs démarches de renouvellement
les cavs sont aussi mobilisés pour
délivrer aux familles notamment aux
familles monoparentales des aides de
secours individuel à titre exceptionnel
vous évoquez enfin la situation des
familles les plus précaires qui font
face des dépenses supplémentaires
pendant cette période de confinement et
vous proposer une allocation spécifique
je vous confirme que nous sommes
attentifs à cette question et que nous
les étudions avec attention
pour conclure je voudrais adresser
quelques mots et remercié tous les
bénévoles les salariés les agents de la
protection sociale mais aussi les
travailleurs sociaux qui oeuvrent pas
leur engagement quotidien car la
solidarité en temps de crise n'est pas
une option je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre la parole pas
monsieur arnaud viala pour le groupe
l'est républicain
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre monsieur le ministre je
souhaite vous interroger avec mes
collègues bernard perrut jean marie
sermier didier quentin aisne et
l'ensemble des députés du groupe l'est
républicain sur la situation de nos
ehpad
au moins 2400 personnes ont succombé au
coronavirus dans les ehpad de france et
ce bilan va s'alourdir encore
considérablement dans les prochains
jours certains établissements sont même
décimés par des vagues de décès
absolument effrayante
nous devons impérativement protéger les
pensionnaires et les personnels des
ehpad les masques sur blues et gèle
commence à peine à leur parvenir mais
mieux protéger les ehpad cela passe à
présent par une démultiplication des
tests que vous limité pour l'instant aux
seuls premiers cas par établissement à
défaut de dépistage en pleurs la
stratégie retenue de l'isolément
systématique n'est pas satisfaisante
tant elle soulève de délicates questions
à la fois éthique et fonctionnel nous ne
pouvons pas durablement couper
totalement du monde de nos parents et
nos grands parents alors infligeant une
épreuve de solitude est une immense
détresse
nous ne pouvons pas non plus durablement
contraindre beaucoup de personnel
à se confiner avec les résidents faute
de meilleure solution mais questions
sont simples
quand comptez-vous mettre réellement en
oeuvre un dépistage massif dans les
ehpad et comment comptez-vous atténuer
le sentiment d'isolement des résidents
de ces ehpad
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
député la parole est à monsieur olivier
ferrand ministre des solidarités de la
santé monsieur le député arnaud viala
j'ai déjà dit tout à l'heure que les
ehpad sont un lieu d'attention
particulière les personnes en ehpad sont
des personnes qui le plus souvent ont
perdu une bonne part de leur autonomie
l'âge moyen est de 85 ans est ce que les
français ignorent peut-être c'est que
c'est souvent la dernière demeure des
personnes fragiles âgées
il y à chaque mois plus de dix mille
personnes qui décèdent dans les ehpad en
dehors de tout contexte épidémique donc
ce sont des personnes particulièrement
fragile aussi au regard de chaque
épidémie de grippe est évidemment de
coronavirus raison pour laquelle des
décisions difficiles en termes de
confinement et de protection ont été
prises difficile pour les personnes
âgées
difficile pour les salariés qui
travaillent dans les ehpad difficile
pour les proches aidants pour la famille
limiter les visites c'est une décision
qu'on prend vraiment en apposant et
croyez moi aucun dépistage ne remplace
le confinement je vais vous expliquer
pourquoi
si vous avez demain dépister alors qu'il
n'y a pas de cas asymptomatiques chez
pearson la totalité des soignants et des
résidents et que du coup vous dites y'a
personne qui est positif on va donc
permettre les visites des soignants de
la famille etc
vous pouvez faire entrer le virus et
puis quand bien même vous avez des
pistes et tout le monde de lundi
effectivement des négatifs qui vous dit
que le mardi a pas quelqu'un qui sera
contagieux qui viendra travailler
donc à moins de dépister en permanence
les soignants vous ne pouvez pas à part
ce qu'on appelle un screening
c'est-à-dire un dépistage suffisamment
précis ce que nous faisons c'est que
nous proposons de resserrer les mailles
du filet en allant des pistes et
davantage dès la première alerte dès
qu'une personne est malade je l' ai déjà
dit tout à l'heure la faisabilité
nécessite un travail gigantesque qui va
associer les collectivités les élus des
territoires les départements les maires
les agences régionales de santé la
réserve sanitaire
la puissance de l'état les hôpitaux les
ehpad elle-même c'est un chantier
gigantesque que celui que nous avons
annoncé une guerre c'est un objectif
très fort que nous nous fixons parce que
c'est à ce prix que nous pourrons encore
renforcé le niveau de sécurisation au
sein des ehpad archi monsieur le
ministre j'ai le député monsieur le
ministre il n'est pas du tout dans mes
habitudes être polémique et je ne veux
pas l'être mais la séance de questions
telles qu'elles se déroulent et le seul
moment où actuellement nous députés
pouvant vous interroger sur les
décisions prises nous y tenons beaucoup
parce que par ailleurs la démocratie
souffre de la situation et je le
regrette je vous ai demandé tout à
l'heure quand la sérologie serait
disponible vous ne m'avez pas répondu je
vous demande maintenant quand les tests
vont être déployés à une plus grande
échelle dans les ehpad parce que je
comprends vos arguments je vous ai
d'ailleurs écouté avec attention ce
matin mais nous avons besoin d'avoir des
dates
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
député nous poursuivons maintenant entre
séances avec des questions portant sur
des thèmes économiques et sociaux
la parole est à monsieur jean louis
bricout pour le groupe socialiste et
apparentés merci une seule président
monsieur le premier ministre le
gouvernement s'emploie à trouver des
solutions pour gratifier celles et ceux
qui se mobilisent en cette période de
crise négocié avec régis juanico et mes
collègues du groupe nous proposons une
prime exceptionnelle pour les agents
publics en première ligne pour autant je
voudrais attirer votre attention sur la
situation particulière des auxiliaires
de vie qu'elles soient recrutés par le
secteur privé associatif ou par une
collectivité territoriale
les auxiliaires de vie ne pourront
profiter pleinement d'une gratitude
financières de type prime macron soit
parce que la législation ne permet pas
soit parce que les structures qui les
accueillent n'en n'ont pas les moyens
il serait regrettable qu'elle soit une
nouvelle fois oublié comme c'était le
cas avec les mesures gilet jaune
pourtant nous leur devons beaucoup
quelle famille n'a pas n'a pas eu ou
n'aura pas recours à ces personnels
ce personnel essentiellement féminin
arpente le territoire pour accompagner
nos aînés quand les familles sont trop
éloignées
ou trop occupés en semaine ou le
week-end elles entrent avec délicatesse
dans lui qui est l'intimité des familles
dans des logements quelquefois inadapté
il effectue les tâches les plus ingrates
doit s'accommoder aussi de l'excellent
exigences des familles le tout pour un
salaire de misère un temps partiel
imposé des horaires à coupure en cette
période de confinement trop soucieux de
la situation de nos aînés ces personnels
ont malgré tout continué à assurer la
continuité du service en prenant des
risques pour leurs familles cette
situation je crois nous oblige il nous
appartient de trouver ensemble une
mesure qui puisse les gratifier à titre
exceptionnel c'est pourquoi je vous
propose de doubler le taux des heures
effectuées en période de confinement nos
parents grands-parents et celles et ceux
qui s'en occupent valent bien un effort
de la nation pour compenser cette charge
exceptionnelle de structure je remercie
merci monsieur le député la parole est
un monsieur olivier du shop secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre de l'action et
des comptes publics merci à monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés monsieur le député bricout vous
avez évoqué la question des auxiliaires
de vie des encore à domicile et je
voudrais d'abord commencé cette réponse
en vous indiquant mais vous le savez que
le gouvernement aimerait pénicaud peut
en témoigner à veiller à ce que ces
personnels quel que soit leur statut
quel que soit le statut de leur
employeur puisse être éligible au
chômage partiel
j'entends la demande qui est la vôtre
d'une revalorisation d'un accompagnement
j'ai la conviction que cela trouvera
aussi sa place dans lordonnance présenté
par madame la ministre du travail lors
du dernier conseil des ministres
vous avez aussi évoqué la question des
auxiliaires de vie des aides à domicile
employés du secteur public et à travers
elle la situation des fonctionnaires les
agents publics titulaires ou
contractuels
c'est l'occasion pour moi de saluer
l'engagement de dire que les mots
manquent convives on illustre combien
ces hommes et ces femmes sont attachés à
l'intérêt général et aux services
publics etc à travers leur nom à travers
leurs visages c'est aussi la solidarité
nationale qui prend corps nous avons
veillé concernant le secteur public a
d'abord maintenir le revenu de toutes
celles et ceux qui sont concernés par
des mesures de maintien à domicile
dans le cadre du confinement c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous privilégions
le placement en autorisations spéciales
d'absences et que nous avons accompagné
les collectivités beaucoup emplois des
aides à domicile pour que les agents
contractuels
les agents titulaires attendant complet
il rompt retrouve à nouveau beaucoup des
métiers que vous avez évoquées puissent
pour les collectivités locales
être soutenu par la caisse nationale
d'assurance maladie c'est un dispositif
exceptionnel pour accompagner les
collectivités prendre en charge une
partie de la rémunération maintenu des
personnels des collectivités
territoriales dans le cadre des
autorisations spéciales d'absence
au delà nous voulons aller plus loin
tony à l'engagement du président de la
république pour reconnaître l'engagement
des personnels soignants bien évidemment
en payant les heures supplémentaires
manière majoré en travaillant sur des
éléments de primes exceptionnelles
nous le préparons sous l'autorité du
premier ministre nous le préparons aussi
pour reconnaître l'engagement des
fonctionnaires publics de l'état qui
sont mobilisés dans cette crise qui sont
eux aussi sur le terrain en
accompagnement et dans l'application des
plans de continuité d'activité et enfin
puisque vous avez évoqué les employeurs
territoriaux
je tiens à vous dire que je reçois
chaque semaine plus tôt que j'entends
chaque semaine
l'ensemble des employeurs territoriaux
qu'ils m'ont demandé est-ce que des
collectivités puissent verser une crime
défiscalisées et exonérées de
cotisations sociales
modulable à leurs agents il faut un
véhicule réglementaire ou législative
pour cela nous y travaillons mais cela
est à l'étude et avec monsieur le
premier ministre nous savons combien
mais l'ensemble des personnels et merci
mme sont essentielles dans ces colonnes
merci la parole est à monsieur eric
coquerel pour le groupe de la france
insoumise ou est-ce que cette question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
au nom de la santé de la sécurité des
français monsieur le premier ministre je
veux vous demander de limiter l'appareil
productif d'autres pays au plus strict
nécessaire
je suis responsable politique et j'ai vu
ce qu'il nous en coûte de mater des
activités non essentielles dans le pays
j'ai vu de nombreux élus candidats
militants assesseurs de bureaux de vote
lourdement touchée parce que les
élections municipales ont été maintenues
ne commettez pas la même erreur
monsieur le premier ministre vous savez
comme moi que la courbe de l'épidémie
ici suit la courbe italienne avec dix
jours d'écart
or le 9 mars le président du conseil des
ministres italien giuseppe compte est
déclaré comme le gouvernement français
aujourd'hui que l'appareil productif
devait continuer de fonctionner pour
douze jours plus tard le 21 mars
rattrapé par l'ampleur de l'épidémie de
covile 19 être contraint de déclarer
l'arrêt de toute activité de production
autres que celles strictement nécessaire
nous ne devons pas nous mentir nous
allons nous aussi être encore durement
frappés vous l'avez d'ailleurs signalé
bien votre ministre de la santé ce matin
hier le ministre de l'intérieur
déclarait la nécessité de durcir le
confinement nous selon nous savons que
cela se fait aux risques de limiter
toujours plus les libertés individuelles
sont il faudra par ailleurs reparler
mais ce ne peut être avec une injection
injonctions contradictoires avec les
appelle à reprendre l'activité
économique car dans trop de secteurs il
n'ya tout simplement pas de protection
suffisante pour éviter la contamination
dans les transports en commun comme sur
les lieux de travail
maintenir voire promouvoir le travail
salarié ou non dans certains secteurs
ces exposés des vies celle des proches
des travailleurs à des risques inutiles
prendre le risque de renforcer la
propagation du virus
je pense par exemple aux annonces de
mcdonald's qui compte 1 reprendre son
activité
c'est contre-productif cela va retarder
la sortie du confinement
nous avons l'occasion de ne pas être
pris de court cette fois c'est pourquoi
je vous demande quand allez vous
concentrer des moyens de protection
optimum sur les activités strictement
indispensables au pays et faire arrêter
les autres merci la parole est à madame
muriel pénicaud ministre du travail
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés sur le député eric
coquerel la question que vous posez
c'est dans un contexte de crise de
confinement qui doit travailler pour le
bien de la nation et comment on doit
travailler et les deux questions sont
étroitement liés sur le premier sujet je
crois qu'on nous en avons déjà débattus
il est très difficile de dire qu'il ya
des secteurs importants et d'autres qui
ne le serait pas je vais vous donner un
exemple on va tous être d'accord pour
dire que l'alimentaire est vital il faut
que les français
confiné puisse se nourrir et pour se
nourrir il y annonce appelons le
supermarché mais avant il y a les
entrepôts la logistique
il y a les transports il ya les
mécaniques la mécaniciens qui répare à
des transports avant il y a
l'industrie agroalimentaire il y à
l'agriculture il ya une partie de
l'emballage
il ya une partie très important de
l'économie qui pour cette seule activité
est mobilisé donc lorsqu'on regarde
l'activité économique de bout en bout
c'est une sorte de dominos qui est très
interdépendants c'est pour ça que c'est
difficile de répondre à votre question
et que c'est le choix différemment que
différents que nous avons fait
d'ailleurs l'italie qui a essayé de
faire une liste n'arrête pas d'ajouter
la liste tous les jours à cause de cette
interdépendance des secteurs néanmoins
on peut faire quelque chose c'est la
manière de travailler
car actuellement nous sommes déjà dans
un service économique minimum environ la
moitié de l'activité est complètement à
l'arrêt ou largement ralenti mais les
conditions c'est la santé et la sécurité
des travailleurs là dessus ce cycle nous
rejoignons c'est pour ça que depuis deux
trois semaines nous avons mis en place
une équipe projet qui produit avec les
professionnels et je consulte tous les
deux jours les partenaires sociaux sur
ce sujet des guides impératifs des kits
de bonnes pratiques métier par métier il
ya déjà 13 métiers qui sont ressortis 20
qui sortent cette semaine c est nous
faisons aussi des contrôles et nous
contrôlons les entreprises pour vérifier
qu'elles mettent en place ces mesures
elles ont une obligation de moyens c'est
dans le code du travail et elles ont une
responsabilité pour organiser le travail
de façon à pouvoir protéger les salariés
nous les aidons part c'est par ces
guides mais nous les contrôlons aussi et
donc le choix n'est pas économie ou
santé mais continuer la vie des français
et en même temps protéger les salariés
merci madame le ministre la parole était
monsieur marc de lattes pour le groupe
la république en marché une question de
monsieur eric girardin la merci monsieur
le président je pose ici la question de
mon collègue eric girardin député de la
marne qui associe à cette question notre
collègue thierry benoit député d'ille et
vilaine cette question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'économie et
des finances bruno le maire la crise que
nous traversons n'est pas uniquement
sanitaire mais également économique le
gouvernement a bien saisi l'ampleur des
conséquences en mobilisant une enveloppe
de 45 milliards visant à soutenir les
entreprises et sauvegarder les emplois
je tiens d'ailleurs à souligner l'action
et la mobilisation de votre ministère et
de ses services des acteurs privés se
sont également engagés dans cette crise
je pense ici aux banques mais également
aux assureurs
ainsi le 23 mars la fédération française
des assurances a annoncé la
participation de ses membres au fonds de
solidarité à hauteur de 200 millions
d'euros
cette action s'ajouter à celles déjà
annoncées le 19 mars et visant à
maintenir l'ensemble des contrats de
garantie des entreprises en difficulté
en cas de retard de paiement et ce
durant la totalité de la période de
confinement de nombreux professionnels
souhaitent un effort supplémentaire en
demandant la reconnaissance de
catastrophe naturelle au titre de la
pandémie pour que les pertes
d'exploitation subies au cours de cette
pandémie soit prise en charge
cependant il semblerait qu'aucun
mécanisme en dehors des stipulations
contractuelles spécifique ne permettent
cette prise en charge
dès lors si ministre madame la
secrétaire d'état
le gouvernement travaille t-il sur la
mise en place d'un outil juridique
visant à prendre en charge ces pertes
d'exploitation et sur d'autres
mobilisations de la part des assureurs
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
la parole et à madame agnès pannier rue
nash et secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre de l'économie et des finances
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
madame et messieurs les députés monsieur
le député vous mentionnez effectivement
la question de la participation des
assureurs à cet effort collectif que
chaque entreprise et chaque particulier
est amené à faire aujourd'hui c'est une
question où vous avez souligné je vous
en remercier le travail qui a été fait
par le ministre de l'économie et des
finances pour faire en sorte que cette
participation des assureurs soit
immédiate concrète et pragmatique c'est
l'effort qui est fait au travers du
fonds de solidarité des entreprises avec
200 millions d'euros 200 millions
d'euros qui seront immédiatement versés
dans les prochains jours aux très
petites entreprises qui en ont le plus
besoin aujourd'hui
effectivement il cet effort doit être
complémenter il va être complémenter par
l'effort qui est fait par rapport aux
entreprises qui pourraient être privés
de la capacité de payer leurs primes
d'assurance et ça les assureurs se sont
engagés et je crois savoir qu'il y aura
une réunion avec l'ensemble des
assureurs demain au niveau de monsieur
le premier ministre pour faire en sorte
de continuer à travailler sur cette
participation des assureurs au-delà de
ça s'agissant du régime de catastrophe
sanitaire
comme vous le savez cela n'est pas
praticable à date pour des raisons
malheureusement juridique la catastrophe
naturelle c'est un régime qui est
obligatoire qui porte sur les dommages
aux biens
la catastrophe sanitaire fait peu de
dommages aux biens et en l'occurrence ne
figure pas dans tous les contrats
d'assurance et ne fait pas l'objet d'une
prime payée par tout le monde qui permet
de partager ce risque est d'avoir une
réassurance qui est géré au niveau de
l'état et c'est bien pour ça que nous ne
pouvons utiliser ce dispositif
en revanche rien ne nous interdit et
nous allons le faire de commencer à
travailler sur la mise en place d'un
dispositif de couverture de la
catastrophe sanitaire pour le futur de
façon à ce que nous ne soyons pas dans
cette situation et à devoir organiser
autrement
la contribution des assureurs à l'effort
collectif je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre monsieur
delattre le groupe la république en
marche une autre question de madame
aurore bergé cette fois oui merci
monsieur le président cette question de
ma collègue aurore bergé s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de la culture
franck riester le confinement bouleverse
profondément notre vie quotidienne
elle nous prive du lien avec nos
familles nos proches et nous oblige à
réinventer des espaces de lien social
plus que jamais la culture et les médias
démontre le rôle central qu'ils jouent
dans nos vies chaque jour les créateurs
se mobilisent ils dessinent ils
s'écrivent il interprète il joue il
donne à réfléchir sur le moment que nous
vivons tout autant qu'il nous permet de
nous en évadés les opérateurs culturels
publics et privés nos théâtres opéras
musées bibliothèques ont répondu à cet
appel
chaque jour les médias publics et privés
se mobilisent il nous permet de nous
tenir informés il offre à nos familles
un accès renouvelé à la culture tout
autant qu'à des programmes éducatifs
scientifiques et de divertissement mais
le monde de la culture et de la
communication ont subi de plein fouet la
crise les cinémas les librairies les
théâtres les salles de spectacle les
musées ont été les premiers à devoir
fermer
les tournages et les enregistrements
sont à l'arrêt les tournées festival
reporter et les recettes publicitaires
de nos médias connaissent des chutes
brutales entre 70 et 90%
le gouvernement a d'ores et déjà
débloqué 22 millions d'euros dette
directe pour le secteur culturel milieu
le salon il faut aller plus loin
les artistes et les techniciens du
spectacle avaient des contrats signés
qui ne peuvent être honorées
seront ils pris en compte dans le calcul
de leurs 507 heures un fonds spécifique
pour les théâtres et les scènes est il
prévu le fonds de solidarité est ouvert
aux artistes auteurs mais leurs revenus
sont versés de manière irrégulière et
pour ils peuvent différer
considérablement d'un mois à l'autre
comment cette spécificité va être prise
en compte enfin les médias n'ont jamais
connu de telles baisses de leurs
ressources publicitaires
cela peut fragiliser durablement le
financement de la formation tout autant
que celui de la création audiovisuelle
et cinématographique
ce sont notre souveraineté et notre
diversité culturelle qui sont en jeu
j'ai proposé la mise en place d'un
crédit d'investissement pour les
annonceurs afin d'anticiper d'amorcer la
reprise économique et de soutenir le
secteur de la communication
quelle est pour cela votre avis monsieur
le ministre je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur franck riester ministre de la
culture dont nous saluons leur
établissement merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés
monsieur le député tous les secteurs
d'activité de notre pays sont touchés de
plein fouet par cette crise
à commencer par le secteur culturel
c'est la raison pour laquelle le
ministère de la culture toutes ces
équipes en lien avec les autres
ministères à veiller à ce que les
professionnels les artistes les
intermittents du spectacle les
entreprises de du spectacle puisse être
intégré au dispositif de portée générale
pour faire face à cette crise d'un point
de vue économique et nous continuerons à
travailler avec les différents
ministères avec les professionnels
concernés à faire en sorte qu'ils soient
bien inclus dans tous les dispositifs
permettant de faire face à cette crise
encore une fois tant pour les
intermittents du spectacle les artistes
auteurs pour les professionnels du
spectacle vivant
c'est la raison pour laquelle je vais
présenter très prochainement
cette semaine un plan spécifique pour le
spectacle vivant hors musique c'est la
raison pour laquelle hier j'ai annoncé
la création d'une cellule de crise pour
les festivals pour que chaque festival
puisse avoir un interlocuteur tant en
région
dans l'hexagone ou en outre-mer ou en
administration centrale pour pouvoir
avoir des réponses en tout cas pour
pouvoir échanger sur les problématiques
auxquelles ils sont confrontés en lien
avec les autres ministères concernés et
nous préparons bien évidemment la suite
mais nous sommes d'abord et avant tout
concentré sur les moyens donnés à ces
acteurs-là pour passer cette crise et
c'est vrai pour l'audiovisuel qui est
particulièrement touchée par cette crise
également en remerciant les journalistes
en remerciant les professionnels de la
presse des médias qui maintient aussi
audiovisuelle qui nous permettent de
continuer d'être informé de proposer à
nos compatriotes des programmes adaptés
à ce confinement avec un évidement un
satisfecit tout particulier pour
l'audiovisuel public qui a permis
notamment de s'inscrire dans le projet
de nation apprenantes qui nous permet
aujourd'hui de proposer des contenus
éducatifs à nos compatriotes et nous
allons dans les semaines qui viennent
continuer de travailler avec les
artistes avec les professionnels de la
culture pour leur permettre de passer ce
moment terrible cette crise et en même
temps préparer l'avenir pour que demain
les arts et la culture puisse continuer
d'être aussi exceptionnel dans notre
pays qui l'ont toujours été
merci monsieur le ministre nous
poursuivons cette séance avec des
questions portant sur des thèmes divers
toujours en lien avec la crise sanitaire
ce monsieur michel claise boere pour le
groupe e du mouvement démocrate et
apparentés qui pose une question de
madame josy pouyeto oui merci monsieur
le président ma question s'adresse à
madame la ministre garde des sceaux
au nom de ma collègue des pyrénées
atlantiques josy poeyto madame la
ministre nous le savons cette période de
confinement propice et une à une
recrudescence voit une recrudescence des
actes de violence conjugale et
intrafamiliale des mesures efficaces ont
très vite été prise en place et une mise
en place par vos soins pour faciliter
l'alerté grâce par exemple à la
mobilisation des pharmacies aux appels
préventive des forces de l'ordre ou
l'utilisation du 114 pour prévenir par
sms mais une fois la personne violente
identifiés ou interpellé se pose la
question de l'après dans sa
circonscription de pomas collègues josy
poeyto est sollicité par des
associations qui se préoccupent comme
nous tous des mesures susceptibles de
porter secours dans l'urgence aux
victimes
l'enjeu désormais est de déterminer les
conditions rapides de décohabitation
autant qu'elle soit possible la seule la
semaine dernière il a été annoncé que
l'état financerait 20me nuitées d'hôtel
supplémentaires pour assurer la sécurité
des personnes menacées
même si nous pensons que c'est
l'éloignement du conjoint violent qui
doit être la règle afin que la victime
conserve la jouissance du logement
en ces temps difficiles c'est une bonne
mesure le gouvernement a également
annoncé la mise en place d'une plate
forme d'hébergement pour l'éviction des
auteurs de violences cette plateforme
devait être ouverte vendredi dernier est
mise à la disposition des procureurs
s'il semble logique que le nombre place
dépendra de l'identification des besoins
exprimés sur le terrain pouvez vous
préciser s'il vous plaît madame la
ministre
comment va s'articuler ce dispositif
afin d'être rapide et efficace merci
merci chers collègues la parole était
malade nicole belloubet garde des sceaux
ministre de la justice
merci monsieur le président mesdames les
députés madame la députée messieurs les
députés monsieur le député effectivement
la préoccupation madame la députée
pouilles pweto est la nôtre également et
c'est la raison pour laquelle dès lors
que les juridictions ont été fermés j'ai
demandé que le suivi des violences
intrafamiliales continuent à être
effectuées
parce que ce sont des contentieux
prioritaires et urgents et donc au
moment où je vous parle
et ordonnances de protection continue à
être délivré les comparutions immédiates
ont lieu mais il est également essentiel
d'assurer les mesures d'éloignement qui
sont prononcées par les juridictions et
c'est la raison pour laquelle avec ma
collègue marlène schiappa nous avons
décidé de mettre en place un dispositif
qui est un dispositif exceptionnel et
temporaire et que nous voulons très
efficace et très immédiat la plateforme
d'orientation d'éviction des conjoints
violents répond à cela elle a été
ouverte non pas vendredi mais hier et
cette plateforme on peut la saisir par
courriel soit lorsqu'il s'agit
d'officier de police judiciaire si par
exemple les procureurs ne poursuivent
pas au pénal mais ont ordonné une mesure
d'éviction soit par les services publics
d'insertion et de probation service
pénitentiaire d'insertion et de
probation ou les associations
lorsque le procureur a ordonné une
mesure de contrôle judiciaire
avec l'éviction du conjoint violent
cette plateforme
elle évalue les disponibilités de
logement chez nos partenaires habituels
en cas d'insuffisance elle peut faire
appel à des nuitées hôtelières vous
l'avez rappelé qu'ils sont prises en
charge par le gouvernement et en 24
heures nous avons déjà reçu dix demandes
qui correspondent à son objectif dans
différents départements
il peut s'agir des demandes qui viennent
de la petite couronne parisienne où des
demandes de départements plus ruraux et
notamment des pyrénées atlantiques
puisque je pensais répondre directement
à madame la députée polito donc ces
demandes sont variables et nous devons y
répondre en 24 heures est d'ores et déjà
des demandes ont été satisfaites je
pense notamment à l'une dans le haut
rhin
il me semble donc que nous avons
construit un dispositif qui répond à son
objectif l'efficacité et l'immédiateté
je crois que c'était essentiel pour nous
merci madame la ministre la parole est à
madame béatrice descamps pour le groupe
u10 agir et indépendant oui merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation nationale monsieur le
ministre la crise sanitaire dans
laquelle se trouve notre pays a
nécessité bien sûr la fermeture des
établissements aux élèves mais un
dispositif de continuité p
dago gic est assuré par les enseignants
que je tiens ici à remercier et à saluer
leur travail conséquent chronophage pour
maintenir un contact régulier avec leurs
élèves
entretenir les connaissances et leur
faire accords y acquérir de nouveaux
savoirs dans ces conditions
inhabituelles ce n'est pas simple et j'y
ajouterai aussi si vous le permettez les
associations et municipalités qui
contribue elle aussi surtout dans nos
petites communes à aider ces
établissements légitimement plusieurs
questions se posent aujourd'hui malgré
l'amélioration de l'enseignement à
distance
l'égalité entre les élèves est remise en
cause
de par les différences d'accès à
internet le manque de matériel
informatique dans les écoles dans l'est
à la maison la possibilité des familles
d'aider leurs enfants ou bien d'autres
phrases encore aussi je voudrais vous
interrogez monsieur le ministre sur ce
manque qu'il y aura forcément dans les
apprentissages qu'auront nos jeunes de
tous niveaux et en satiné et cette
inégalité qui va s'accroître encore
comment ces élèves vont ils pouvoir être
aidées la rentrée de septembre sera
t-elle préparer en conséquence
en ce qui concerne les examens le choix
du contrôle continu est selon moi un
choix juste
toutefois les professeurs s'étonne que
les moyennes de première ne soient pas
prises en compte
enfin de nombreux parents et lycéens
s'interroge quant au jury
d'harmonisation et à l'octroi des
mentions pouvez-vous rassurer les élèves
de lycées noté sévèrement entre
guillemets durant l'année scolaire en
précisant justement le rôle et le
fonctionnement de ces jurys et si j'ai
encore deux secondes je terminerai en
vous demandant monsieur le ministre si
les mesures de carte scolaire ouverture
me
mesures seront prises ou ont été prises
pour la rentrée de septembre
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
la parole à monsieur jean michel
blanquer ministre de l'éducation
nationale et de la jeunesse
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
béatrice descamps
d'abord je souscris à votre triple
hommage hommage aux professeurs qui sont
en première ligne pour assurer cette
continuité pédagogique aujourd'hui
hommage à tous les personnels de
l'éducation je pense aux au chef
d'établissement au cpe à l'ensemble des
personnels qu'ils sont avec les
professeurs notamment pour aller
chercher tous les élèves
et puis hommage finalement à l'unité
nationale
parce qu'on sent bien en ce moment que
derrière les professeurs il ya en fait
tout le pays à commencer par les parents
d'élèves bien entendu dans une forme de
d'associations de complicité de
d'alliance pour aider les enfants chacun
comprenant bien que professeur c'est un
métier que c'est difficile et que les
professeurs de france sont engagés pour
nous pour nos élèves
cet hommage il le renvoie aussi à tout
le travail qu'il ya à faire pour
compenser les inégalités qui peuvent
être croissantes à l'occasion d'un
épisode comme celui que nous vivons
puisque chacun est renvoyé à son
contexte familial est là aussi
a contrario on voit l'importance de
l'école de la république qui permet de
combattre les inégalités quand le
fonctionnement est normal et cette
conscience accrue de ce fait nous elle
est importante pour pour la suite alors
il ya ce que nous faisons pendant la
crise et ce que nous ferons après la
crise pendant la crise nous allons
chercher les élèves c'est tout le
quadrillage que nous faisons et auquel
je faisais référence avec les chefs
d'établissements en particulier et ceci
nous permet de diminuer jour après jour
le nombre d'élèves qui ne sont pas
inclus dans la continuité pédagogique
il en reste encore mais nous réussissons
ça là aussi parce que nous sommes un
grand service public de l'éducation
nationale ensuite des moyens spécifiques
du matériel informatique prêter grâce
aux collectivités locales souvent et au
monde associatif avec lesquels nous
sommes la main dans la main et puis il
ya aussi des dispositifs particuliers
avec la poste qui doit qui va nous
permettre à partir de cette semaine
d'envoyer des documents rédigés par les
professeurs par la poste avec une
enveloppe permettant l'envoi gratuit
ensuite par la famille aux élèves que
nous n'arrivons pas à atteindre par
internet
c'est aussi le coup de fil hebdomadaire
je n'ai pas le temps de répondre à
l'ensemble de votre question mais oui
après la crise au moment de la rentrée
il y aura des dispositifs pour
personnaliser les parcours et tenir
compte des éventuels retards qui ont eu
lieu à cause du confinement
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
ministre la parole est à monsieur
stéphane peu pour le groupe de la gauche
démocrate et républicaine
oui merci cette question s'adresse au
ministre de l'éducation depuis désormais
quatre semaines d'école est arrêté
certes votre ministère tente de
maintenir le lien entre l'enseignant et
l'élève est d'assurer la poursuite des
apprentissages mais nous voyons bien à
quel point cette prétendue continuité
pédagogique se heurte à d'importantes
difficultés
l'indisponibilité des parents qui
travaillent le manque de compétences car
il suffit pas d'avoir fréquenté l'école
pour savoir enseigner et enfin le manque
d'outils car dans nombre de foyers
modestes le seul lien vers l'internet
c'est le téléphone pas d'ordinateur
encore moins d'imprimantes et parfois
rien du tout dans les zones blanches de
nos campagnes vous admettez déjà avoir
perdu le contact avec 8 % des élèves
mais dans bien des territoires c'est
beaucoup plus dans mon seul département
de la seine-saint-denis votre
administration chiffre à un tiers le
nombre d'élèves qui sont en rupture de
scolarité et sa s'élève à 60% dans
l'enseignement technique
il est désormais clair que l'école à la
maison risquent d'accroître un peu plus
les inégalités scolaires
monsieur le ministre nous ne pouvons en
accepter des graves et durables
conséquences pour les élèves jeu on sait
par exemple que les enfants de cp
c'est au coeur de ce trimestre que ce
fait pour eux l'envol vers la lecture et
l'écriture mais seule minute il ne faut
pas ajouter une crise scolaire
à la crise sanitaire oui il faudra un
plan massif de rattrapage il sans doute
également adapter les programmes pour ne
pas entériner les retards pris par
certains élèves
pouvez-vous d'ores et déjà au moment où
vos administrations annonce des
fermetures de classes dans dans nos
mairies
annoncé ici devant la représentation
nationale un moratoire sur les fermes
les fermetures de classes et enfin je
n'avais pas prévu de finir ma question
de cette manière mais je vais le faire
ce midi j'ai appris deux manières en
étant je le confie abasourdi que sur les
1200 postes supplémentaires que vous
avez annoncé le 27 mars dernier
il y aurait zéro poste pour la fin de
saint denis qui est par ailleurs le
département le plus jeune le plus
populaire de france et qui en ce moment
vit et subit un lourd tribut à la crise
du coc vie de 19 alors monsieur le
ministre rassure et nous en nous
informant que c'est pas une information
mais une fake news et au moins je
n'aurais pas perdu mon après midi
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
monsieur jean michel blanquer ministre
de l'éducation et de la jeunesse qui
préfère le mot balivernes affectés aux
rapports merci monsieur le président et
mesdames et messieurs les députés de sur
le député stéphane peu et donc en effet
je vais vous rassurer et sauver votre
après-midi et davantage il s'agissait d'
une baliverne votre département cela
seine saint denis
cette année aura des créations de postes
127 créations de postes ce qui en fait
un des départements où il ya le plus de
créations poste comme c'était le cas de
l'année dernière où c'était 10 % des
créations de postes nationale j'aime m'a
pas échappé que certains élus de
seine-saint-denis avait fait une tribune
sur sur le sujet alors même que nous
sommes en train de battre des records
historiques de taux d'encadrement
favorable en seine saint denis pour la
rentrée prochaine
donc je voudrais que pour l'ensemble de
la france
7 ces échanges que nous avons chaque
année à la même époque se fasse de
manière tout à fait transparente et
claire on ne peut pas parler des
fermetures quand on ne parle pas d
ouverture il ya beaucoup plus
d'ouvertures que de fermetures en seine
saint denis et nous allons accomplir
l'épreuve les promesses du président de
la république en matière de dédoublement
des classes de grande section à 12 en
répétant et or est plus même chose
évidemment ces pays c'est là où c'est la
plupart du temps déjà fait et nous
allons en effet être à la hauteur de ce
qui est nécessaire dans ce département
avec je vous le dis des taux
d'encadrement qui vont être record et
l'engagement que j'ai pris avec grâce au
premier ministre qui après un arbitrage
sur ce sujet c'est que nous
vont plus de fermetures de classes sans
l'accord du maire en milieu rural et en
milieu urbain analyse avec le maire du
taux d'encadrement ont chaque commune et
le solde ouvertures fermetures dans
chaque commune se traduira forcément par
une amélioration du taux d'encadrement
c'est l'engagement que nous avons pris
vous pouvez le vérifier commune par
commune
si vous trouviez une exception à ce que
je viens de dire eh bien je suis prêt à
corriger les choses puisque c'est un
engagement que nous avons pris donc
c'est vous dire à quel point nous sommes
je pense à la hauteur de la situation
qui nécessite en effet de meilleurs taux
d'encadrement à l'école primaire et
cette personnalisation des parcours des
élèves dont a parlé là la députée
béatrice descamps tout à l'heure et qui
en effet un deux impératifs de la
rentrée prochaine je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre la parole à
monsieur arnaud viala pour une question
de madame emmanuelle antony du groupe
l'est républicain
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président je suis effectivement le
porte-voix de d'emmanuel anton député de
la drôme monsieur le premier ministre
samedi matin c'est avec effroi que nous
avons appris qu'une terrible attaque au
couteau avait eu lieu en plein coeur de
romans sur isère
ce jour là un jeune soudanais réfugié en
france depuis juin 2017 a violemment
assassiné deux personnes et en a blessé
cinq autres qui se sont retrouvés en
urgence absolue
notre émotion est grande et mes pensées
vont aux victimes et à leurs proches à
qui j'adresse à tous mon soutien je
tiens à saluer le travail exemplaire des
forces de l'ordre des sapeurs-pompiers
et des personnels soignants dont la
réactivité a permis une nouvelle fois de
sauver des vies je souhaite que toute la
lumière soit faite sur ce qui s'est
passé
le parc national antiterroriste s'est
saisie de cette affaire
des premiers éléments il ressort la
nature terroriste de cette attaque
des documents manuscrits à connotation
religieuse ont été retrouvés dans
lesquels l'auteur se plaît notamment de
vivre dans un pays de mécréants avec cet
événement tragique
ce sont à nouveau des familles anéanties
des vies brisées fauché en pleine rue
par la folie obscurantistes du
fondamentalisme islamiste
d'où qu'il vienne où qu'ils soient nous
devons le combattre et ne pas baisser la
garde pour défendre des valeurs
républicaines auxquelles nous sommes si
fortement attachés
cette attaque s'ajoute à toutes celles
qui précèdent et nous rappelle même en
ces temps troublés par la crise
sanitaire que la lutte antiterroriste ne
doit souffrir d'aucun répit face au
fondamentalisme religieux
le gouvernement doit être intraitable
mais nous avons le sentiment que trop
peu est entrepris pour protéger les
français
après les discours du président de la
république sur le séparatisme
nous attendons encore des actes quand le
gouvernement s'attaquera t-il en face au
fléau islamistes je vous remercie
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
monsieur christophe castaner ministre de
l'intérieur merci monsieur le président
madame messieurs les députés
monsieur le député évidemment je savais
aussi emmanuel antoine qui a suivi
minute par minute samedi ce qui s'est
passé dans sa circonscription en effet à
10h45 le parcours meurtrier d'un homme
qui a attaqué sept personnes et en a tué
2 a meurtri notre territoire notre
territoire national bien évidemment
évidemment au delà de la seule commune
de romans-sur-isère je me suis rendu
l'après midi sur place pour d'abord
porté mon soutien à la maire de la
commune madame thoraval qui était
totalement mobilisé avec ses services
pour apaiser apaisée tant les tensions
étaient fortes dans la commune marquée
au mieux de la torpeur liés au
confinement et à la chaleur début d'été
que nous connaissions sur place et j'ai
vu combien cette ville était meurtri et
combien elle était engagée aux côtés de
ses habitants pour les accompagner puis
aux côtés de nos forces de sécurité
intérieure il vous est saluée
j'ai pu effectivement les saluer parce
que dix minutes après que l'alerté était
donnée ils ont pu neutraliser
l'assaillant et faire en sorte qu' il
soit mis à disposition de la justice
pour être interrogés l'enquète était
d'abord placé sous l'autorité du
procureur local
puis elle a été compte tenu des éléments
qui sont remontées au fil des heures de
ce début d'enquêté sous l'autorité du
procureur national anti terroriste qui
est vous avez rapporté quelques éléments
considère qu' il y a matière à instruire
aujourd'hui au moment où je vous parle
pour
qualifié de terroriste je voudrais
saluer l'ensemble de notre de la
mobilisation de nos forces d'abord dans
le cadre de cette enquête 150 policiers
spécialisés sont totalement mobilisés
pour faire la pleine et entière vérité
et transparence sur cette affaire pour
que nous puissions vérifier qu'il n'ya
pas de risques liés à ce fait qui s'est
produit à romans sur isère et qui
pourrait par des effets robes on se
retrouvait sur le territoire national
mais je voudrais aussi vous rassurer
monsieur le député sur l'engagement
total de nos forces de sécurité
intérieure qui font preuve d'un
engagement total malgré le contexte et
en particulier ceux qui au sein de l'as
date dans la cedh dcpj au sein de la dg
à six sont totalement engagés au moment
où je vous parle comme à chaque instant
pour faire en sorte que nous puissions
veiller au meilleur niveau pour empêcher
ou des jouets ou échouer des attentats
61 l'ont été depuis 2000 13 19 ont
échoué et nous le devons aussi au
travail remarquable que font ces femmes
et ces hommes qui dans l'ombre protège
des français merci monsieur le ministre
la séance des questions au gouvernement
est terminée je vous remercie de sortir
de manière échelonnée prochaine séance
mardi 14 avril à 15h questions au
gouvernement
la séance est levée